- Welcome to Vegas.
Welcome to re:Invent 2025.
You are in ANT 307,
operating and scaling managed
Apache Kafka and Flink.
My name is Ashish Palekar.
I take care of our Kafka, Flink,
and Firehose services here at AWS,
which means that I spend
time talking to customers,
but also building the service,
but also operating the service.
With me is...
- I'm Sai Maddali, I
lead the product teams
for our Amazon managed streaming
for Apache Kafka, managed
service for Apache Flink
and Amazon Data Firehose.
- Very cool.
So today we are going to cover a bunch
of what we are doing with
our Kafka and Flink services.
We're gonna walk you through our learnings
and compare and contrast,
give you a sense of what we've learned
and hopefully we can cover a
lot of details in the session.
So let's get started.
As we go through it,
a lot of customers often
start with why streaming data
and why now?
It really boils down to four things
that we hear from customers.
It's about unlocking
real value from your data
in real time as it flows,
helps you make decisions in real time
and shorten the time to
actually get to insights.
You can get continuous
intelligence from that data.
And last, but not the least,
as we are continually seeing
now with AI workloads,
you need more contextualized data.
You need more fresh data.
And streaming technologies
help you get that.
Here at AWS, we love Kafka and Flink.
We have had Kafka and Flink services
for well over five years at this point.
And in fact have been operating
workloads for customers.
We have customers who also
use self-managed Kafka
and Flink in addition to ours.
And there's certainly other
partner solutions as well.
But really, we see a large
and wide variety of
workloads across the board.
So one of the things I
get asked by customers
is what are the outcomes
that customers look for
when running at scale?
What do customers really care about?
It really boils down to price performance,
boils down to reliability,
boils down to security
and boils down to performance.
These seem like basics,
but at the same time, at
scale, these are magnified.
And every one of you
that is operating a Kafka
or Flink service knows that.
Just by show of hands,
how many of you operate a Kafka service?
Vast majority of you. Awesome.
So that this helps Sai later on,
how many of you use Flink?
Few of you. We'll talk about that too.
Thank you for being our customers.
These are some other customers.
Customers make our world go round
and this is absolutely super
helpful for us to understand
what customers are doing.
So let's talk about
running Kafka at scale.
Always love to start
with a customer example.
Nexthink, Nexthink is a customer
based out of Switzerland
and really focus on how to go
build developer experience.
Their core problem
was how to help scale their
Kafka business, switch to MSK.
They were running on premises,
switch to MSK on AWS, and
they can process now trillions
of events a day, reaching
five gigabytes per second
of aggregated throughput.
Really has been compelling
to watch their journey
in scaling from 200 megabytes
to five gigabytes per second.
And that has taught them,
as well as us a whole bunch of lessons
and as we observe workloads
across our customers.
So when we think about
the spectrum of Kafka,
and I'll speak to sort
of the services we offer,
we think of it across a
two-pronged spectrum, right?
Like, on the left-hand side,
you have more Kafka control
and on the right-hand side,
you have more Kafka automation.
In the more Kafka control
case, we offer standard brokers
for Amazon MSK.
This is the case when you're migrating
from an existing Kafka setup.
You need fine grained control for Kafka
and have deep know-how
about how Kafka works.
And that becomes important.
On the other end of the spectrum
is Amazon MSK Serverless
where you can quickly
deploy and scale up Kafka.
You don't need Kafka
management and you don't need
or care about the nuances
of managing Kafka.
And in between, this is
something we launched last year,
last November, is Express brokers for MSK
where you value performance and elasticity
where you want or need
lower control over Kafka.
And typically what we see is
this is a set of customers
that is managing Kafka at scale.
And this is something
I provide as guidance
to customers when I talk to them.
Unless you know differently,
always recommend you start from Express.
It's a good place to
start for your workloads
and then decide where to go.
So across this family of products,
we see a diversity of Kafka workloads
and it gives us really,
really interesting insights.
We see customers operating
at small scale, large scale.
with a high partition count,
low partition count, combinations of both.
And that entails different things.
One of the first areas
that I'll talk about today
is about storage management.
And this starts to get tricky,
especially at scale.
Specifically, storage scaling takes time
and as we started looking at it,
you can go from four terabytes
to eight terabytes to 12 terabytes.
All of this is possible.
One of the things we
consistently see is customers
who are not monitoring
their storage utilization.
In fact, your storage
utilization can spike.
You can start to start to see
that grow as workloads change.
If you haven't already, there
is something MSK offers,
you should subscribe to disk full alerts.
You get alerts at 60% full, at 80% full
and then when it's actually full.
But that will alert you to make sure
that your capacity is
actually taken care of.
One thing we noticed is it
is easy to scale up capacity,
but you don't have a capacity scale-down.
And that is something
that trips up customers.
And so customers often
delay making a decision
about scaling up and
something that is a tension
that you need to wrestle
with as customers.
Recognizing that, one of the things we did
is when we built Express brokers,
we eliminated storage management.
What we operated with is really started
with not having any storage configuration.
Just tell us your attention period
and we are off to the races.
You get virtually unlimited
storage capacity per broker,
which means you really don't
have this conceptual notion
of what a disk full looks like.
Your storage is provisioned
per cluster versus per broker
and that obviously has cost savings,
but equally importantly makes it easier
to sort of imagine what your
overall workload size is
and then you pay for what you use
versus needing provisioned capacities.
And last but not the
least, you get hands free
and instant scaling on the storage side,
and that is also super useful.
So if you really look at
sort of the core tenets
of how we worked on storage management,
if you think about it
in the Express context,
our focus was we wanted to
eliminate storage management
for you and that entailed
doing all these five things.
The other area that that we see
where customers are challenged with
is around failure handling.
And so you say, "Well,
what does that mean?"
Well, here what we have
is a three-broker cluster.
You have producers, you have consumers,
you have consumers in the consumer group.
The producer is producing
to two brokers here.
So what does the basic traffic look like?
You have producer traffic,
you have consumer traffic,
you have replication traffic,
and depending on your workload,
you have partition compute needs, right?
Very rarely we do encounter workloads
or I guess not so rarely,
we do encounter workloads
that are partition bound.
And so you have to
account for that as well.
And this is the basic configuration
that as customers you need to account for,
which is what's my producer traffic?
What's my consumer traffic?
What's my replication traffic
and what are my partition compute needs?
And then failures happen.
Let's say a broker dies.
What happens in that case?
You need buffers for
handling broker failures.
How does that look like?
Your producer swaps,
your replications switches,
your leadership changes,
and then the broker comes back,
which means your first broker
has to actually account
for the throughput of
two producers, right?
Now your broker comes back
and now there's different workloads
that you need to account for.
What is your catchup replication?
What does that look like, right?
And eventually, then as
the broker rebalances
and producer reswitches,
you also need to account
for what happens when there's
a consumer rebalancing.
And there is some
interesting new innovation
that is happening in the
Kafka space around us.
But all of these are things
that you have to build in
when planning your workloads.
Too often we encounter customers
who have workloads that work fine
when things are going fine,
but when failures happen,
that's when they encounter problems.
And these are some things
that we ask customers
to sort of think through.
What does your failure
handling actually look like?
But failure recovery is also time taking.
So it's not just about having the space
and buffers to actually
account for these failures.
It's also accounting for time.
And specifically in this case,
what happens is in the
standard Kafka case,
you're scaling compute
and storage together,
and especially after a
node recovers from failure,
it has to catch up.
This process is time consuming,
but it's also non-deterministic.
What does that mean?
It's dependent on what is
your storage throughput?
What is your storage capacity?
What is your compute to local
storage network throughput?
So you have all these
different factors that are sort
of competing for attention
in that infrastructure,
which means your recovery time
is going to be dependent on that.
Interestingly, Kafka is a
remarkably stable system
until failures happen.
And at the point that failures happen,
then the thing that
you can do as customers
is to wait for recovery.
And that often is where a lot
of our customer conversations happen
is around how have you
thought about failure recovery
and failure recovery in these modes?
On the Express side, looking at that,
what we ended up doing
is really rethinking
how failure recovery happens.
Because we separated our resources,
what that means is your recovery
is up to 90% faster, right?
And that fundamentally means
that you're getting high resilience
because your mean time to recovery is low.
And that is a phenomenally important thing
when you're designing
resilient distributor systems
is how do you keep your recovery time low
so that you can build
resilience for your systems.
And I'll walk you through some examples
of what that looks like.
But that is how Express
brokers is different.
What does that mean
for horizontal scaling?
Everyone has a plan until they have
to rebalance partitions, right?
And that is what Kafka
horizontal scaling looks like.
You add three brokers,
you're going to go move partitions across.
You have to reserve enough
bandwidth for rebalancing.
You have to carefully
orchestrate the movement
so that it does not impact
your existing workloads.
And last but not the least,
you're continuously
monitoring your infrastructure
so that if there's a need
to change the plan, you can.
And that's what happens.
Rebalancing can take hours
and again is variable.
And that is how the system behaves.
On Express brokers, because we
have separation of resources,
what that fundamentally
means is you can get up
to 20x more elasticity
compared to standard brokers.
I often get this question from customers,
which is what does elasticity mean?
So let's look at an example.
How fast can I rebalance my partitions
after adding brokers while
traffic is still climbing?
Here's an experiment that we ran.
We had three brokers, one
topic, 2,000 partitions,
four terabytes of data per broker.
What we did is we had three brokers
and we added three brokers,
rebalanced 1,000 partitions,
all this while producing
90 megabytes per second .
Pretty typical for what we see.
And what we did is compare
standard to Express
and I'm just gonna show you a
couple of CloudWatch graphs.
So here's what standard looks like.
You have three brokers
that are at the top.
On the left red line is
where we issued the command
to add three brokers.
You can instantly see
the throughput drops.
And the throughput drops
and continues dropping
and eventually the new three
brokers start to pick up.
And you can see the throughput sort
of gets throttled further
and eventually the throughput stabilizes
and behaves as if it's six brokers, right?
So you get producer degradation
until the throughput recovers
and that entire process takes
about 175 minutes, right?
And so you are going through
this partition rebalancing
and adding three brokers
until you get productive six
brokers for about 175 minutes.
Here's what this looks
like for Express brokers.
The left is where we
added the three brokers.
Yep, the brokers went
to the new throughput
and within 10 minutes,
the remaining three brokers were added
and they joined the cluster
and produced the traffic.
Again, from a customer standpoint,
and for you as users of this,
what that means is
you're spending less time
doing partition rebalancing,
which is giving you a
more resilient system,
which also means you can scale
up and scale down faster.
You can run this experiment
and see what your results look like.
But wait, there's more.
What we announced a few weeks ago
for Express brokers is
intelligent rebalancing.
What we've now done is you
get always-on rebalancing,
you get auto partition placement,
you can do fully automated
horizontal scaling
with zero click automated heat management
and that gives you
improved price performance
from a cluster standpoint.
And here's what intelligent
rebalancing looks like.
You get up to 180x faster rebalancing,
which means shorter recovery
windows and higher resilience,
and that is as compared
to standard brokers.
One of the interesting
things the team did,
which really is sort
of well thought through
is you get built-in operational awareness.
In other words, we detect
when there's healing going on,
when there's patching going on
and we prevent unsafe overlap.
And last but not the least,
we apply all our best
practices for scale-in
and scale-out intelligence
before resizing our clusters, right?
And so that becomes enormously helpful
in terms of giving you a signal
of what workloads your brokers can accept.
So super happy that this
is in customer hands,
it's available for Express brokers
and it's starting I think two weeks ago.
So one of the other thing
was we had to rethink
what resilience looks like.
And part of this is to
help you understand sort
of how we think about resilience
and all the work that we had to do to sort
of build in resilience.
Here's what standard
Kafka behavior looks like.
You have a broker, I sort of modeled it
as you have a broker with
partitions, you have memory,
you have compute, you have
network, you have storage.
Kafka classically is an
allocate when asked system.
You sort of can request capacity,
it'll give you capacity,
you can create a partition,
it'll create a partition.
And what happens is the
onus is on Kafka clients
and the users to not overload the system.
And the challenge with that
is you only find out you've
overloaded the system
by monitoring it well,
by having heuristics,
by having experience of
managing your workloads.
But when that overloading
happens, it causes broker failures
and so you are in the mode
of recovery at the point
that you've overloaded the brokers.
So one of the things
that we did in Express
is you have the same model for a broker,
but for each of those, we
have added safe throttles
safe dynamic throttles on
compute, memory and networking.
And what that means is we
can start to minimize sort
of the impact on the broker
and protect the broker from failures.
In fact, the team has
also had to think through
what does it mean to
survive storage failures?
Now, you can't survive storage failures
for an infinite amount of time,
but still it builds in resilience
and gives you the capacity,
at least for a while,
to survive without storage being there.
And last but not the least,
especially as we throttle,
your client can then react
to the throttling behavior it sees
instead of just seeing the failure
and then reacting to the failure.
So what that means is
from a design standpoint,
you actually have the ability
to design your system,
to take cognizance of like
the system being overloaded
and actually accounting
for it differently.
And that is something that
is fundamentally different
about what we had to do
in order to re-architect for resilience.
So it goes further, deeper.
One of the other things
that we did with Express
is we made it such
that you did not need a
maintenance window for patching.
We also built in partition-level fairness
and what does that mean
is you get protection
from noisy workloads.
So you can't have a single partition
taking up all the
throughput of your broker
and you get better protection on that.
Last but not the least, one of the things
that the team has also
had to think through
is what does it mean to stop
potential cascading faults
and how do you isolate them by design?
Nothing's perfect, but
there's a lot of thinking
that had to go in in
terms of building systems
that can survive.
And so part of like
walking you through this
is to help you understand
what does it mean to actually operate
and run these systems at scale?
Now, there are some customers who'll come
and tell us we want even lower management.
And so all of this infrastructure
and all of that knowledge
we built into MSK Serverless
and there you're just operating
at the level of scaling up,
scaling down, you're doing
zero Kafka management
and normally we recommend
it for new to Kafka
or new to streaming customers.
I debated putting this slide up
and I debated very, very deeply
about like, it seems remedial
and yet it's one of the more
common failures that we see
with customers is monitoring Kafka.
What I'll show you on the
next slide will seem obvious,
but it's remarkable how
customers, like a lot of customers
are not set up for
actually monitoring these.
So these are the things
we recommend you monitor
in your Kafka setup.
So I'll start with the per
broker, per cluster things.
It's partitions per broker,
total partitions per cluster,
it's connections per broker,
monitor these, right?
It's super important to make sure
that these are within the bounds
and in fact set alerting so
that you can react to this.
And then on the usage side,
think about your broker CPU usage,
your disk usage, your memory usage,
your throughput usage.
It is amazing how these simple metrics
will give you a view on what
it means for the service
and the system to operate.
Super important that you balance
not just the operational
side of running the system,
but also the monitoring
and making sure that you're
doing the right thing.
That is what it means
to run Kafka at scale.
Up next, Sai will tell
you about what it means
to run Flink at scale.
- Well, thank you so much, Ashish.
So now that you've got
all the data streamed
in Apache Kafka, you need to process it
and that is where running
Apache Flink at scale
comes to fruition.
So how many of you have
some of these use cases,
anomaly detection where
you're transforming data
before you're loading
that into an OLAP system?
How many of you're supporting building
event-driven applications?
If you're using any of those use cases,
or all those three use cases,
then you should be using Apache Flink.
There are four reasons
why. First, it's real time.
Second, it's great at
handling dynamic datasets.
Number three, it's stateful and
finally, it is programmable.
Let's dive deeper into each
one of these using an example.
Imagine you are building
a fleet monitoring system
and your goal is to detect anomalies
as quickly as you find them
so that way you can improve
the customer experience.
So I start with a few nodes
and within no time, my fleet
grows and now I have tens
and hundreds of nodes and
in no time, I have thousands
of nodes to monitor and detect.
What is equally important to remember
is as your customers are
creating new resources,
you have new nodes to monitor
and when they're deleting resources,
you no longer have to monitor those nodes.
So this set of data that you're
monitoring changes rapidly.
Somewhere along the line
you realize that, "Look,
my anomaly detection can be better
if I also include storage
monitoring into the mix."
And then eventually
software versions, regions.
So very quickly what you see
is a big increase in
complexity of your data.
This is where Flink's
continuous processing
is a lot better than using
batch-based processing.
A batch is like capturing a photo.
A photo captures what's
true in the moment.
You cannot track what happened before
or potentially what has happened after.
Comparatively a video captures
every frame, every detail.
It gives you all the rich
context available for you.
You can go pause that, go
back to a point in time,
compare different things
and get to the insight in
a more accurate fashion.
We also talked about one
of Flink's strength being it's stateful.
So in our example, you're able
to capture the state per key,
per server, per software type.
And as new events come in,
that state is incrementally
updated by Flink.
And what it does, it waits
for patterns to emerge
and either decides, "Well, this is noise,
I'm gonna suppress it
or it's a valid signal,
let me act on it."
So in our example, it could
be a breach in threshold
where you say,
"Well, I wanna monitor if I
have more than five faults
in any given minute and if
it breaches that threshold,
I want to trigger an automated action,
which is replacing that faulty
node before the customer
is actually seeing impact."
So being stateful gives you
that rich memory for you
to make more context-aware decisions.
The last piece is it's programmable.
So in our example of fleet monitoring,
you can start with a
simple if-then-else logic.
If this happens, I'm gonna do this.
But over time you realize,
well, I wanna also monitor my storage
so it can evolve your logic
to now also include other metrics.
You can also map the data to
a table in a database table
so that you can actually
enrich that context.
And finally, you can
start with simple actions.
In my fleet monitoring
example, that customer started
with creating an alarm
so that a human can react
to that alarm and replace that node,
but over time they grew confidence
in operating that system
and started taking automated
action using that workflow.
So this gives you that ability
to constantly evolve your application.
The combination of
real-time, statefulness,
being able to handle dynamic datasets
and programmability is also the reason
why customers are turning to Flink
to build agentic AI applications.
So what does it take
to do more data processing
workloads real time?
When we talk to a wide
variety of customers,
three particular patterns emerge.
First, it requires a change
in your operating model.
Second, you need resilient
Flink infrastructure
and finally, build programming
logic that is robust.
It sounds obvious but it's very important.
Let's start with what do we mean
by changing the operating model?
And a good way to understand
that is to compare that
with batch-based processing,
something that has been
popular over the years.
In the batch world, your
data is largely fixed.
So you're processing data
that is either days old
or a few hours old
and the analyst is now running
different set of queries
to find that insight.
And then essentially
also leaning on a human
to generally take an action.
Compare that in a streaming system.
Data is getting continuously generated.
And then on this set of
continuous generating data,
you're applying a set of
generally static rules
to understand insights and
almost automate the action.
So in our fleet example,
the automation there
is replacing that faulty
node or storage device.
Time is explicit in the dashboard.
When you take a photo,
the snapshot tells you
that this was taken at
this particular time.
But when it comes to video,
you have to specify that time explicitly.
I wanna go to this particular timeframe
and then compare things.
So time is explicit in streaming systems.
So that is what we mean by
changing operating model.
You're moving away from
dynamic queries on static data
to static queries largely on dynamic data.
That also means that as developers,
there are some new
concepts for you to learn.
First is event time,
which actually tells you when
the actual event has happened,
not when it's processed.
Sometimes as an example of
fleet monitoring system,
you could get events related to storage
before you get events related to server.
If you end up using processing time,
you would miss processing
events related to your server
and that means your action
would not be accurate.
So leaning on event time
becomes very important.
The second key concept is Windows.
Because you have this
continuous flow of data,
Windows allows you to group this events
into small buckets for analysis.
The next important
concept is partitioning.
That essentially is
how data is distributed
so that you can parallelize
your processing.
Now, because Flink is
trying to process data
at really high throughput and low latency,
partitioning becomes very important.
Lastly, one of Flink's strong calling card
is its support for
exactly once processing,
which means that as a
developer, I get the confidence
that I'm not worried about duplicates
when it comes to processing.
So I'm processing each event exactly once.
So how does Apache Flink
support high throughput data
at low latency with
remarkable consistency?
The answer lies in its architecture.
The job manager is like a
brain for the Flink system.
It is planning, scheduling,
coordinating the work.
And then you have task manager
where the actual processing is happening
and the task manager is further
broken down into task slots,
which aids for parallel processing.
So here's how it works.
So you deploy, you build your logic,
you deploy it as a JAR,
and then job manager takes the code,
first translate that into
a logical unit of work
and then breaks that into
physical units of work
and places those work in task slots.
Why? Because it wants to
guarantee parallelism.
Flink also captures the state,
we've talked about how important that is,
and periodically
checkpoints its processing
into a durable store within S3.
And the reason it's doing that
is to give you the guarantee
of exactly one's processing,
but also be resilience
when failures happens.
So when a job fails, when
infrastructure fails,
it needs to know where to start
and how to start those
operators processing data again.
So this combination of
orchestration with job manager,
parallelism driven by task manager,
as well as checkpoints give
you the right set of perimeters
for you to run at scale.
But as an administrator,
what are all the activities
I'm responsible for
to run these systems at scale?
They largely fall into three categories.
First is deployment, second is monitoring,
and the last is scaling and evolution.
So your developer comes to you,
they wanna build an application.
So starting point is you pick
an infrastructure provider,
Kubernetes-based system.
Then you have a choice to make,
whether you wanna run
that in application mode
where you have a dedicated
set of infrastructure
for that job or you
wanna run in session mode
where you can run multiple jobs
on that same set of infrastructure.
And for most at-scale applications,
you choose the application mode.
Then we're off to monitoring
once you've deployed the infrastructure.
And we'll dive deeper into this subject,
but the core goal there is to make sure
that you're always processing data.
And finally, scaling the
system is super important.
And we've talked about how programmability
and evolution are so key
perimeters for Flink.
And so your goal there is to
monitor when you need to scale,
do the scaling event, also
support deploying new code.
So that's what it looks
like as a life cycle
of a Flink job and the
activities around it.
Now, for developers running applications,
this is a fairly involved process.
So at AWS, we offer managed
service for Apache Flink
that provides the
easiest way for customers
to build resilient Flink applications.
So the developer experience
with our managed services
is far simpler compared
to the deployment example
that I gave you before.
So in here, there's no
infrastructure set up.
You get built in multi-AZ resiliency
and there is no configuration tuning.
And here is how it works.
You go to your favorite
IDE, build the application,
get a JAR file out of it,
create an application
within the managed service,
and then you're off to the
races to start processing data.
There's no computer managed,
there's no configurations
for you to set up.
Now you've got this thing up and running,
now you have to operate it.
And what I'm gonna do
next is kind of walk you
through our learnings operating
Flink applications at scale
and how you can potentially
benefit from it.
And I'm gonna focus on
two specific learnings.
The first one that we've
learned is in Flink,
a significant change can lead
to processing being interrupted.
So what is a significant change?
Could be you're trying
to scale the system.
Could be you are trying
to handle a node failure
or it could be you're doing patching
and software upgrades.
In each of this case, what
happens is Flink says,
"Okay, well, I detect
a change in the system,
let me pause everything,
let me reassign things,
and then resume processing."
So our first goal in operating
the system is making sure
that we are minimizing
these processing delays.
How do we do that?
The key to do that is to
separate the time it takes
to spin up EC2 instances
and other prerequisites from
the overall job downtime.
So you separate those things out,
and we do that with two
specific techniques,
which is one is blue-green deployments,
the other is having a warm pool.
With blue-green deployments,
we do not stop the job until we set up
and verify the prerequisites.
Here is how it works.
First, we spin up the
necessary EC2 instances.
Next, we verify your job configuration,
we'll make sure all the
prerequisites are met.
And at that point is when
we are switching over
from the old infrastructure
to the new infrastructure
and resuming processing
from the exactly same point
at which you stopped
processing previously.
The next key concept is warm pools.
So instead of waiting for
EC2 instances to spin up
and the amount of time it takes,
we maintain a warm pool of infrastructure,
thereby we get an instance
that is ready to go.
So the combination of
blue-green deployments
and warm pools is how we reduce the time
and how we reduce a job downtime
when there's a change in the system.
Another key aspect that we've talked about
is how Flink allows you to
change and evolve your logic.
So our fundamental goal
is to how do we make
this whole process simple
for our developers or for our developers?
We wanna be repeatable, fail proof
and quick so that they can
consistently make changes.
So how does this work?
Well, a developer decides that
you wanna go make changes,
build a new JAR file
with their code changes and they submit
to the managed service.
And what we detect that
there's a new deployment
that is happening and we do
not stop the job right away.
We take a snapshot of
the current running job,
durably store that in S3
and then the managed
service sets up this new job
with the configuration,
sets up the new infrastructure,
including EC2 instances,
make sure they're spinned
up and they're running.
Sets up the job configuration,
validates the things
and then restores the state
from what it has stored within S3.
So now your operators are
running with the preserved state
and that is when you switch
over to the new infrastructure
and you resume processing.
We also pair this with smart guardrails.
The goal there is to detect
any known code issues
and thereby doesn't impact job processing.
So the way this guardrails
work is as an example,
imagine you upload a new code
and it has some null pointer exceptions.
It detects that this
code is having issues,
it automatically reverses back
to the last known good state
of this application and starts
to resume the processing.
So a combination of automation
and the orchestration
of how we deploy new code,
blue-green deployments
and smart guardrails
is how we give developers the confidence
to constantly evolve their applications
in a highly resilient way.
The second learning, the first learning
that we talked about
is any change in Flink
means there is a job downtime
and how do we minimize it, right?
The second key learning
we've had is a lot of times,
developers and administrators in Flink
are working with different abstractions.
Developers are thinking
about core logical operators
and then admins are
thinking about resources,
its utilization, and they have
no visibility into the core.
And same way, developers
have no visibility
into the actual infrastructure.
So we recognize there is a need for them
to have a common mental model
and how to reason about Flink.
And there are two key shared mental models
that we recommend customers.
First is fixed unit.
The second is how do we
think about job availability
and not just infrastructure availability?
Let's talk about fixed units.
Typically it's very hard
or very unpredictable
to map the Flink code
to the actual resources like
task managers and task slots.
It's very unpredictable, hard, complex.
And the reason is that is
different task managers
can have different
performance characteristics
and depending on how you've created slots,
that can have different
performance characteristics.
So you have a pretty unpredictable system.
And the goal with fixed units
is to bring predictability
into the system.
So in our managed
service, the smallest unit
of provisioning is a KPU,
which gives you a one vCPU,
four gigabytes of memory
and 50 gigabytes of storage.
So what it does
is now you get deterministic
performance per parallelism.
Each lane is also isolated.
So the trouble with noisy
neighbors is no longer an issue.
It also makes debugging easier.
So when you have hot slots
or issues, it's very easy to detect
where exactly it is
happening as an administrator
and resolve that very quickly.
Lastly, it simplifies scaling.
So if you want to add more capacity,
you simply add more parallelism units.
And then you also get
predictable state slices.
So things like checkpointing
and backpressure management
becomes a lot more consistent
for application admins.
So what does fixed units do?
For developers, what it means
is your workflows are simple.
Now you can design your
code so that they fit
in a fixed budget.
And then once you figure out
what that deployment profile looks like,
then you can scale that by
simply adding more KPUs.
And for administrators, by
enforcing these guardrails,
you are being more proactive
rather than being reactive
when it comes to handling issues.
So that is a role of the fixed units.
The second common way that you want people
to reason about Flink
is to think about job availability
rather than infrastructure availability.
Now, job availability tracking
in Flink is very hard.
Flink states whether the job is running,
doesn't always mean that
data is getting processed.
Why is that the case?
There are three reasons
why that may happen.
First is the boundaries between user code.
Flink runtime and external
systems are not always clear.
So debugging is very complex.
Second is restarts and
recovery means a lot
of times the underlying
root cause is masked.
The second run, which starts
producing different errors,
will mask the errors
that were actually caused
by the original problem.
That makes troubleshooting very hard.
Finally, issues can happen
that are external to the Flink runtime.
Think about node failures,
storage failures.
So it's important to track
them and address them.
So what we recognize is we need
a smarter detection system,
a system that can detect that
there's an issue, classify it
and be very surgical about the
action it's trying to take.
So what we built is a system
that consistently monitors a Flink job,
looks to classify whether
an issue is something
that is related to user code
or is a system-driven one.
A user-driven issue could look
like issues with your code,
like a null pointer exception,
things that have resource exhaustion
that is created from the code base.
A good example of that
is you've opened too many connections,
you've not closed them
or it could be incorrect configurations
that you picked for your job.
All of these are in the category
that are related to user code.
And then you have system-related issues.
And these could look like
node failures, Flink bugs
or generally issues with connectors.
The automatic healer
identifies error causes,
classifies them, and then
the reason the classification
is important is it can be very surgical
about the fix it wants to do.
As an example, if it detects
that there are incorrect configurations,
dynamically, it can change
those configurations
and thereby restart becomes much faster.
And the whole purpose of the system
is to reduce the mean time
to recover from the failure.
Let's dive deeper using a few examples.
The first one is performance degradation.
Imagine you have built an application
for the fault system that
I talked about previously.
It works great for 100 records per second,
100,000 records per second,
but now suddenly you wanna scale that
to 500,000 records per second.
And those specific static configurations
that you picked no longer
work for this increased scale
and Flink gives you 400 plus
configurations to choose from
and that makes the whole process harder.
So what the detection
system does is it detects
that there's an issue with
the incorrect configuration,
fixes that dynamically
and thereby recovers a job very quickly
from the performance degradation.
The second example is something
that we see very typically
is with connectors.
A good scenario for
this is Flink is looking
to restart the job to
recover from another failure.
And then what it realizes
is that there is this process
related to this connector
that is not responsive.
So what the detector does is it detects
that there's an issue with
this connector process,
kills that process externally,
thereby the job can restart very quickly.
Here's an example once
again where the goal
is to recover faster from an issue.
Finally, failures can happen
outside the Flink job,
which we've talked about.
A good example is node failures.
Failures do happen,
infrastructure does fail.
And when it fails, we detect
that there's an issue.
Pick a node from the warm pool
that I mentioned previously
and then accelerate
the recovery process very
quickly for customers.
So again, three examples
where having a detection
system, classifying it,
being very surgical
with what we are fixing
reduces the mean time to
recover from failures.
Now, what we've also
recognized is availability
is also the function of your code.
Issues such as high CPU, out of memory,
this throttling can also come in terms
of how the code is structured.
Let's understand this using an example.
Imagine a customer says,
a developer says, "Look,
I have this high CPU issue."
And you start dive deeping
into that job graph.
And what you realize is
that job has morphed itself
into a wide variety of
subtasks, 1,600 plus subtasks,
and they're trying to
fit that into 10 KPUs.
Now, one way to solve the problem
is to horizontally scale, add more KPUs.
And you're almost like
throwing money at the problem.
The other way to do that
is to look at is the
code structured properly?
A couple of ways to
think about that is one,
is there excessive branching
happening in this code?
Now, back to our fleet monitoring example,
one way to branch is by alarm type.
It's almost like I'm
executing the same logic
and I want to execute
that for each alarm type.
So I have 20 alarm types,
I have 20 branches.
Another way to do it is
hey, is there something
that is common across these 20 branches?
And potentially you can
organize that by window sizes.
You could have one-minute
windows, five-minute windows,
and maybe three minute windows.
So you can go from having 20
branches to three branches.
So instead of throwing
infrastructure the problem,
you are reorganizing the core
so that way you have lesser subtasks
and there you can fit into the 10 KPU
that we've talked about.
Another example is parallelism.
Sometimes what you see is not
all task managers are busy.
There are some that are
running extremely hot
and there are some that are idle.
And that means that you've
picked an operator parallelism
that doesn't work well consistently
across the entire pipeline.
And that is a case where you
could work with a developer
to make sure they care very specific
about the operator
parallelism they're picking
across different parts of the job.
So these are a couple of examples
where how your layout core
can have an interesting side
effect on the infrastructure.
So what it comes down to
is you need another layer of defense
to make sure you're detecting
these issues very quickly.
Now, Flink gives you a raft of metrics
and I'm not gonna spend time
walking through every metric,
but what I wanted to share with you,
a mental model around
what our customers use
when they operate Flink at high scale.
The first category is application health.
And the goal here is not
just the actual uptime,
but also more importantly
is the job making progress?
Because at the end of the day,
it's all about processing data.
The second category is checkpoints.
Checkpoints are Flink's safety
net to recover from failure.
So you wanna have a robust
monitoring mechanism
for these checkpointing data.
So you're looking at
things like is the duration
of checkpointing long?
Are the sizes pretty high?
So you wanna make sure
that system is very robust.
The third important
monitoring area is latency.
At the end of the day,
Flink is a real-time system
and you wanna make sure
you're always processing
the freshest data.
And so one way to do that is
to compare your watermarks
and see if they are slow or fast.
A slow watermark means there
is lag getting built up,
which means that eventually
you have stalled task managers.
So the goal there is to
compare, as an example,
your watermarks with your processing time
to see how behind you are
with the latest data
that is being processed.
The fourth dimension is throughput,
not just the aggregate throughput,
that is easier to monitor,
but also to monitor throughput
to make sure there's
not enough backpressure
being built into the system
'cause say as an example,
there's one part of the workflow
that is getting backed up.
Then what it means is that spreads
across the entire pipeline.
So goal of that is to monitor throughput
at the operator level,
at the sub-task level,
thereby you have the insights
on where exactly within the pipeline
you're having those
backpressure challenges.
So those are the four different categories
on how you can build a
robust monitoring mechanism
for your Flink applications.
You also wanna understand what are some
of the best practices that we can share
with the development needs?
One of the successful patterns we've seen
with customers is where
they've democratized this
on how to build Flink applications
into their enterprise.
So what is a good core and
behaviors and when it doesn't
and what does the anti-patterns
look like on infrastructure?
The first area is timers and watermarks.
Now, we've talked about how
event time is super critical
and so when you don't use event time,
you end up using processing time.
The typical complaint you see is,
"Well, my aggregations are off."
Well, that tells you that
somewhere in the code
people are using processing
time versus event time.
Another scenario with timers
is your watermarks are slow.
So if your watermarks are slow,
this means there's too much lag.
What if they're too fast?
Well, if they're too fast,
you're not waiting long enough
for data that is trickling in slowly.
So you need to find the right balance
between fast and being too slow.
The second area is state hygiene.
And again, state is such
a crucial aspect of Flink,
but you don't wanna keep
everything in that state
for all the time.
What you want is to enforce TTLs,
thereby your evicting state,
as and when it's necessary.
So getting your state management
is super critical in your code.
The third big area is avoiding data skew.
One of the calling cards
of Flink is how you're able
to partition the data,
process each of that chunk independently.
And you do that by using keyBy operators.
Now, what type of operators,
what type of data patterns you wanna use?
You certainly wanna avoid
low cardinality analytic keys
because what happens with
low cardinality cases,
you have some task managers
that are running hot
and some task managers that
are running inefficiently.
So you wanna pick a high
cardinality each time.
Also, you wanna reduce the
number of shuffles you do.
Shuffles are critical because
you wanna shuffle data
because you wanna get data based
on one particular key,
process that data differently.
So you would end up using shuffles,
but using too many means data
is getting shuffled too much.
That also impacts how much serialized time
is spent on serialization.
And that leads to CPU being busy,
garbage collection being slow
and things of that nature.
Lastly, serialization and
schemas play a very pivotal role.
Not all use cases would benefit
from the default serialization.
And when you end up using
the default serialization,
especially for CPU-intense workloads
by doing transformations
and complex transformations,
that ends up again being
an infrastructure issue.
Schemas also play a very important role.
Instead of getting all the data,
then validating it for the quality,
schemas allow you to enforce
that on the producer side
so that the Flink consuming
code is confident that the data
that it's getting is
actually qualitative enough.
In summary, writing the optimal Flink code
will make sure the applicants
are fast, resilient and reliable.
So that brings us to how
and what it takes for us
to run Kafka at scale.
Now, if you want all these capabilities
without the overhead, we
offer our managed services.
So I wanna bring Ashish.
Ashish.
- Yep.
- We've talked about what
it takes to run Kafka
and Flink at scale.
What are some of the top
key takeaways from this?
- Yeah, I think it's a
really pertinent point.
One of our motivations
in doing this session
was actually sharing our experience.
And a lot of the discussions,
I know Sai does as well and I do,
are about customers who know Kafka
but at the same time,
the effects of scale,
when they encounter running at scale
or when they encounter failures
at scale are different.
And one of our learnings
from that was oftentimes,
the only place that you
actually learn about failures
and how you handle them
is when failures happen.
And that's probably the worst time
to actually learn those failures.
And so what we've tried
to do is explain some
of our thinking in terms
of our best practices,
but also explain how we are
building the system ground up
to make sure that these
things are accounted for.
You saw this on the Kafka end
as we transition from standard
to serverless to Express,
and you're seeing this on the Flink end
on how we are applying that.
Part of why we are sharing this
is as you are making your choices
about running your infrastructure,
are able to make a decision
on which of these to apply,
how you'll apply it and how you'll run it.
The last sort of big takeaway from me
and definitely looking
for learning from you
on the Flink side as well, is too often,
customers are running infrastructure
but actually not monitoring the things
that can cause the failures.
And so what happens is
oftentimes when failures happen
or the SOPs are not functional,
then what happens is you discover
that your system is not running
as stably as you thought.
And a part of this
is that there is a shared
responsibility boundary
in terms of managing the infrastructure,
which we will do and we will own.
And equally importantly,
managing the operational side
of Kafka or Flink, which
then you and us as customers
have to have to
participate and partner on.
And that, Sai, is my key takeaway.
Partly what I'm hoping here
is that we can help customers
as they're thinking about their
choices, run better systems.
Anything on the Flink side
that you'd like to add?
- It's very similar to
what we've spoken on Kafka.
I think the three things
are like knowing your shared boundaries.
Now, with Flink, the
shared boundary also means
you're running code, arbitrary code.
So that has a interesting
effects that we talked about.
Second is picking the
right offering, right?
And sometimes you can learn
from our best practice,
our learnings that we
built into our products
and build infrastructure on your own
or use some of our services.
So I think it's very similar
to our learnings on Kafka side as well.
Awesome. Well, that brings to
the end of the presentation.
Now you can try it for yourself,
both MSK Express brokers,
as well as deploy your Flink applications
or managed service for Apache Flink
because at the end of the day,
seeing and trying is believing.
- [Ashish] With that, thank you so much.